Tahj Mowry mourns his first love Naya
Rivera here are the two black-and-white
throwback photos the 34 year old actors
shared on Instagram on Wednesday after
Naya's body was discovered at
California's Lake Piru
earlier this week captioned the first
photo which shows Naya dancing in his
arms quote you will forever be my
all-time favorite dance partner I love
you
the duo can be seen cuddled up in a
second photo along with the caption rest
in power and peace Naya Marie the pair
of seemingly met on set of Tasha's
sitcom smart guy in 1997 the Magic
Kingdom it's a dream come true
Taj also shared a series of old photos
of the longtime friends and exes on his
IG stories Naya went missing on July 8th
during a boating trip with her four year
old son
Josie I love you prior to confirmation
of her death Taj posted a heartfelt
tribute expressing his devastation
explaining that he was holding on to
hope that the Glee star would be found
kin
through the change in time what's more
the actor revealed that he never stopped
loving Naya and wished for the day that
God would bring them back together
calling her his first experience with
everything love intimacy and heartbreak
quote we broke each other's hearts and
then mended them back together more than
once I will never not think of you no
woman has ever measured up what you gave
me or how you made me feel
Taj went on to say that he was praying
for the Rivera family saying he will
love the 33 year old actress forever
quote I know deep down you've always
known how I felt I look forward to the
day where I can see your beautiful face
once more and tell you everything I've
wanted to say that I didn't get the
chance to say Maori didn't reveal when
he and Rivera dated but they were both
child actors Naya actually guest-starred
on smart guy twice first as Tanya in
season 1 so I started thinking that if
you took him to pick up Tanya I wouldn't
be there to see the look on TJ's pace
when they first met it's okay Tanya it's
just not every day the TJ meets such a
pretty little girl it happens more than
you think she returned to the show in
1999 this time as a character needs
Kellie fascinating huh
not really kind of ruins it
so you hear about Hector he was dodging
this dumb girl named Kelly in the can
I'm Kelly I